one of several deadly shootings we've
reported on in the last week the rise in
violence has funeral directors and
morticians speaking out reminding the
community about the impact these
incidents have madison kimbrough shares
their message tonight
the stop the violence march started
around 3 30 this afternoon and was meant
to bring awareness to the influx of
crime that's been happening here on the
west side and also across the valley
local funeral homes slowly processioned
through with empty hearses and families
who had lost loved ones to violence
carried signs and posters with their
family members pictures and the chant
was simple stop the violence increase
the peace about 100 people participated
on foot also driving by honking their
horns and coming together for one common
cause funeral director dr raymond lewis
giddens junior says they've been
planning this event for four months now
and are pleased to see it through we
want to just encourage the community to
be aware of issues that take place day
in and day out where young people older
people are dying from senseless violence
in the community metro assisted in the
march to make sure that traffic ran
smoothly and a reception took place at
true love missionary baptist church to
honor the lives that were lost
and the march that originally started on
owens avenue happened in the same area
where a homicide took place just a
couple days ago the organizers say they
want to open up a funeral home in that
same area sometime next year reporting
in the historic west side madison
kimbrough live local now